in Washington a troubling report on the
U.S economy is Raising new concerns
about a recession that comes as a recent
poll shows more Americans believe we are
already in a recession compared to two
years ago when the pandemic sent the
stock market crashing and layoff surged
Nancy Cordis is at the White House Nancy
good morning
good morning Vlad you know the White
House was anticipating that GDP would be
down for a second straight quarter and
while officials here acknowledge that
the economy has slowed they insist it
was almost inevitable after last year's
explosive growth
our job market remains historically
strong President Biden tried to put a
positive spin Thursday on gloomy
economic numbers if you look at our job
market consumer spending business
investment we see signs of economic
progress in the second quarter as well
Republicans were less Rosy after GDP
fell for a second straight quarter we're
in a recession and it's not the time to
increase taxes or spending economists
say the Slowdown is due in part to
retailers cutting back on inventory As
Americans tighten their belt in the face
of record high inflation plus recent
rate Heights by the Federal Reserve have
pushed up mortgage rates causing
cutbacks in new home construction White
House economic adviser Jared Bernstein
consumer confidence down GDP down what
does that tell you look we know that
Americans are facing real headwinds in
this economy particularly from inflation
but he insisted that doesn't amount to a
recession not with unemployment still
near record lows and consumer spending
up in the second quarter by one percent
but treasury secretary Janet Yellen
acknowledged there there are Global
risks ahead for the economy they include
the outcome of the war in Ukraine
coveted lockdowns in China and pandemic
related supply chain snarls
she said it's hard to know exactly how
long it's going to take for those supply
chain issues to get unsnarled but she
argued that if we really were in a true
recession you'd see Mass layoffs you'd
see businesses shutting down and that's
not what's happening right now Gail
all right Nancy got it thank you